hey take the bus
[Applause]
[Music]
that's not even the line that's
absolutely true hey everybody it's time
for overdue Doctor Who review and we are
up to planet of the dead but before we
start talking about it this particular
episode of Council of geeks is brought
to you by radio versus the Martians it's
a podcast where Mike Gillis and Casey
Dorn a tackle all manner of geeky nerdy
subjects whatever's on their mind and
with a wonderful revolving door of
guests they will talk Planet of the Apes
they'll talk ghostbusters they'll talk
star wars they'll talk aliens and they
will absolutely continue their dive into
every single film Arnold Schwarzenegger
ever made radio versus the Martians at
Radio versus the Martians calm or
wherever you get your podcast so this
would be the well I consider it the
second like the breakup is weird because
sometimes people consider the Christmas
special to be part of the season that
came before but anyways so this is part
of the David Tennant specials and of
them I would consider this one to be the
most superfluous because you know you
could say that the next Doctor is kind
of a bit of fluff but that's also the
Christmas special which specifically has
kind of a tradition of being light and
fluffy and not having a lot to it when
we get to waters of Mars we're gonna be
dealing with some heavier stuff and then
obviously end of time part 1 & 2 well
that's tenants last story this one this
feels like filler and I kind of think it
just is and it's actually kind of
frustrating in a way because
they did a lot to sort of judge this one
up and like make it look good you know
they went on location to a desert they
transported the bus there that's
actually why the bus looks all dinged up
it got damaged in transport it wasn't
supposed to look like that originally as
scripted but you know they go to all
these extra efforts but it's just such a
placeholder of a story it's weird to me
I mean I guess you know they just wanted
to make things bigger and start
experiment I think this might have been
the first one that was shot in HD I
think it was but you know obviously they
were they were trying to you know gear
things up to being bigger and better for
the future of Doctor Who and I can
appreciate that but like hey that said
this is not bad there's good stuff in it
it's just it's very insubstantial it's
especially knowing you know where things
are headed for the next couple of
stories and sort of where we are you
know these these are the closeout for
tenant and this one especially yeah so
okay there was some interesting things
to catch I didn't realize that one of
the bus passengers was Daniel Kaluga
from 15 million merits on black mirror
or get out I did I realize that was here
man hey cool I know him I like that
Mogambo of unit cut comes back sort of
because the previous episode we saw her
in was turn left which was technically
an alternate timeline so we didn't
really know for certain like if she
existed in our timeline this makes her
canon which is cool I don't think we
ever see her again after this which is
actually kind of a waste I have to
wonder if they stopped using her because
I started Ewing using Kate Stewart
instead as their recurring a unit person
but like you could have had both I don't
know so you know there's that the the
various passengers on the bus honestly
there isn't a lot to most
of them they're just kind of there
they're just there to give us a pool of
people for the doctor to save and
they're it's funny there are things
about this story that are by no means
unique to this story but for some reason
they bother me more here than they do
elsewhere so like for example um one
thing that I've already mentioned
bothers me and I'll touch on it briefly
here so I'm gonna talk about the Tri
Devore's really quick so these are the
fly headed yo the flies and boiler suits
like that's that's what it is and it's
not that it's an unprepped unimpressive
you know mask with the animatronic bits
so at least it moves better than the
human Dalek hybrid thing did but
sticking an animal head on a human actor
or just giving us an alien that is
something that we have on earth but
bigger is lazy that is lazy uncreative
design and actually it's not even
limited to the Tri Devore's here because
also we've got the do they even name
them whatever the heck the things eating
everything are they're giant stingrays
from a visual standpoint yes they've got
a metal plate like it's a stingray
that's what it is is what it looks like
so the the creativity and the design
it's just not there but coming back to
the point I was trying to get to I just
couldn't let that pass without
commenting on it the thing about the Tri
Devore is that again it's not unique to
this episode but it bugged me more here
and I have to wonder if I'm gonna have
my eye out for more in the future we
have a pool of people for the doctor to
save and the aliens don't make it
now the doctor himself is trying just as
hard to save the try divorce as anyone
else but the the dismissiveness of the
show itself of the vibe of it there's no
sense of tragedy to these and honestly
it feels incredibly utilitarian because
they're gonna save them well we're gonna
have to figure out or what do we do with
them like we're gonna have to explain
how they're gonna get home uh heck with
it just kill them they don't look like
people no one will care and like that's
true I mean realistically that's true
but it still bothers me like especially
because the doctor in theory he he has
no reason to prioritize humans over
anyone else and yet consistently any
alien who doesn't look human and is in
the pool of characters that might end up
dying they are a lot less likely to come
out of this live it feels like now I
haven't like gone back and run numbers
on this or anything but like just
thinking back off the top of my head
you had the voyage of the Damned via
bannakaffalatta the only one that looked
distinctly non-human he died honestly
you could go back to to the the
impossible plan in the Satan pit the OOD
didn't survive
none of them not a one humans lived lost
a couple of them but no most of the
humans survived yay or I mentioned this
with the doctor's daughter the hath that
goes with Martha over the surface and
dies to save her after that goes
completely unacknowledged including by
Martha herself this is I I feel like
this is something I'm gonna have my eye
on a bit more it's really irritating and
it it again it speaks to
lazy utilitarian writing because this is
the kind of thing you do when you're not
extending the thoughts out for your
premises because again the doctor has
just as much reason to save the alias
species as he does the humans but from a
logistical storytelling and what will
our audience care about perspective well
it doesn't look like a human they're not
gonna be as invest endless we've really
sink a lot of time into it and if it's
gonna bog down the narrative later to
explain what happened to the aliens
after yeah just kill them it's easier I
don't know man that's annoying but I man
I feel like I'm grossing more than the
is necessarily warranted for this okay
so the the other characters that we've
got to play here the big one I've been
talking about yet is Christina lady
Christina de Souza um on paper I kind of
hate her it's just it's trying very hard
like that this episode as far as she is
concerned as a character it's wearing
its intentions on its sleeve because it
is very clear that it wants the audience
to wish the doctor would take her with
him to put all this emphasis on how good
they are together all these lines like
oh we were made for each other come on
really and that all of that and having
her you know have all these skills and
these things and and be eager to go and
like I kind of hate it on paper in
practice she actually doesn't bother me
too much because she has the one thing
that you would need to make that not
completely insufferable which is good
performance chemistry with David Tennant
so that does pretty much save the
character that otherwise would have
really driven me nuts I'm still a little
bit irritated because it is so on the
nose not to mention there's a lot of
them just really cliche stuff
surrounding her I mean from our
cat-burglar opening because you know you
have the completely impractical Sookie
a system that is not like anything that
I could exists in real life and has a
really obvious weak point and like she
pulls her mask off before she's even out
of the building and you know again I get
over all this is going for a lighter
feel I mean like vibe wise it's kind of
picking up a bit more for the feel that
the Christmas specials tend to have
others just a bit of a fun large so I'm
I'll try not to hold that too much
against it but like I don't like that in
the Christmas specials either so you
know I'm not gonna give it a pass on
that basis who else we got what is his
name Lee Evans as as Malcolm I kind of
like him he's a little bit overdone at
times like when he's trying to put out a
fire he's like got a fire extinguisher
and loses control of it that's a little
much but other than that I kind of like
I liked his eagerness and his enthusiasm
and his excitement at talking to the
doctor yet at the same time he sort of
got a certain amount of trepidation like
well I did this was that wrong like he's
kind of endearing and he's kind of
lovable he's another character I would
not have objected to seeing returned who
never does the the inspector who's
hunting down Christina is he's an
inspector sure he blends into the
background much like the other
passengers on the bus I mean David clue
you stood out to me but that's because I
recognized him his character actually
doesn't have a ton to do over any of the
others so I mean overall I'll just come
back to what I said at the start filler
this feels like it exists only because
the makers of Doctor Who felt it would
have been too big a gap between the next
doctor and waters of Mars which aired in
the fall I and I knowing that there
wasn't gonna like gonna be a full series
worth of stuff it's what
thing to make us wait where you're going
to give us a full 13 episodes but given
that they were only gonna give us four
after the next Doctor
I feel like this only exists because
they need they felt like it was too big
a gap like nothing about this feels like
it was a story that needed to be told it
gives us no real progress on the doctors
own progression for where he's headed in
the next couple of episodes it really
doesn't lend itself to that at all it's
not tying off his you know his pain that
his lost which at the very least the
next doctor did do a little bit of it
just it it all it does is give us the
knocks four times prophecy which
honestly is so disconnected from
everything else that goes on here you
could have stuck that in anything so
it's just here and again it's not bad
it's just very insubstantial
that's planet of the dead what do you
think about this one whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
cuz there's buttons and links
there's the like button to big help I
appreciate it you could subscribe you
can check me out on patreon if you want
to support what I do there's a whole
bunch of other things to look out
besides start clicking on things you
don't have to do because at the end of
the day folks I'm your the council I'm
just runnin the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]